I'm sorry mr. Blythe is the internet
running at maximum capacity well that's
the problem I don't know if our servers
can have nonsense
this is digi bit wave we are the
Internet set the internet speed to
double maximum but you don't understand
mr. blatant there could be dire
consequences I said double maximum or
I'll feed you to Grandma over there
you like that Lord okay
no you throw first day okay let's forum
go my live you probably have it it's
kind of like snapchat meets Great
British Bake Off you take live snaps of
food and drink and your postal on this
you go um are you sure you should be
drinking caffeine so you pop yells and
hunters right so Kate how about me and
you slip off for a minute like that
station it I was little a station look
Barry it's done it your ex-boyfriend
I mean he is your ex-boyfriend right you
sir yes I am always a pleasure Barry hmm
Barry jack is just here to help me with
something so this is work-related just
because you're staying late does not
mean you can slack off I'm watching how
are you good thanks um I just need to
submit this tonight and the cycle to the
bouncing me back so university yeah this
dream had to end sometime can did you
bit wave live without me right fixed it
huh dear structure was points in your
back but still not I hit these forms
well what if we just oh it's happened
may God have mercy on us all go may live
well I where where where's the iPlayer
we have a dire situation in people the
Wi-Fi is down jack here so there's no
way to fix it I have a Wrestlemania belt
on ebay that's being outbid from under
me as we speak
yeah if I don't live stream this chow
mein in the next 20 minutes I'm gonna
get knocked off the gourmet life hotspot
why don't you all just go home there
isn't time Jack there isn't time white
dwarf in May take yourself together
Elizabeth she so spit
she's like mega pregnant no um listen
Jack this is gonna sound really stupid
but my application is due in 30 minutes
and that's my when we copy dear God
okay people what about your phones don't
you have 3G I was gonna get an iPhone
but Blythe kept on promising to upgrade
us they never did just look at this
of course the dongle we can get online
with that how we supposed to get into
Blair's office all right people we are
here and we need to get a Bloods office
upstairs it's being guarded by mod here
we need to find a way to distract her
and get into the office the door is
locked but the cleaning lady has a key
and she's well she's right there can we
move this along please
oh my god layers I think your water just
broke are you Lambert
look how in labor or not in labor I am
is irrelevant
there are revenue via dorks going on
beheaded okay I think I have a plan
been writing this for a while now it's
probably my masterpiece think breath uh
III my Bambino is it coming don't worry
my little ER doctor yeah okay
she'sa the Bambino is on on the way
right why did you order this this chow
mein its I'm sorry I cannot watch this
anymore just a little more and you can
go back to work I promise this is a
one-stop mess well means tapa once their
mess
what are you doing
look if I give you 20 quid will you give
us the keys to Blair's office
okay you guys smart little best shot say
Merry Christmas
so um you left some stuff at mine yeah
it's crap I don't need it thanks
well I don't want it okay fine I didn't
mean I call an ambulance man you're like
funny in labor there's a baby coming out
of your vagina but what about inside
warmers I love all the torques can
weightless the toys can use
hey you slept with this look can we
please just get on with distracting
Marta yeah fine yes I slept with vari
and that's why I broke up with you
because I felt really guilty about it
you know what maybe if you weren't so
sleazy and gross and totally
misogynistic and unskilled and a little
bit sweaty actually maybe I would have
done it again I'm sorry okay I have been
a sleaze I think it's time I paid the
price no no you can't I must re it's not
worth that please don't I know what I
have to do how about you and me slip
away for a minute I make that stationery
cupboards a little less
Oh 110 minutes to go okay would you mind
us having a good thank you
you know kid that's okay
things weren't going well and you made a
mistake how about after this is over we
grab a drink and see what happens
that sounds really nice
and I can't believe I almost threw away
garlic it's D here ey apostrophe re my
god
three year old could have written this
mmm might not be how I would wear it but
you might still get in full stopping
there you could do with using the old
paragraph here maybe just a suggestion